le mois dernier la cour pénale
internationale s'était estimé compétente
pour enquêter sur de possibles crimes de
guerre survenue dans les territoires
palestiniens
ce mercredi fatou bensouda la procureur
général de la cpi a ouvert
officiellement le processus
d'investigation
aujourd'hui je confirme l'ouverture par
le bureau du procureur de la cour pénale
internationale d'une enquête sur la
situation en palestine
l'enquète portera sur les crimes
relevant de la compétence de la cour qui
auraient été commis dans la situation
depuis le 13 juin 2014
l'ouverture de l'enquêté a été saluée
par les palestiniens
nous demandons à la cour internationale
de résister à toutes pressions qui
pourraient être exercées sur elle pour
l'empêcher de rendre justice et de punir
les criminels
le hamas est prêt à coopérer avec toute
partie qui peut rendre justice à notre
peuple palestinien et aux victimes et
punir l'occupation pour tous ses crimes
de son côté le porte parole du
département d'état américain a affirmé
son soutien à israël
nous sommes fermement opposés et déçus
par l'annoncé par la procureur de la cpi
d'une enquête sur la situation
palestinienne
nous continuerons à maintenir notre
ferme engagement envers israël et à sa
sécurité notamment en nous opposant aux
actions qui cherche à cibler injustement
israël la cpi comme nous l'avons dit
n'est pas compétente en la matière
israël ne fait pas partie de la cpi et
n'a pas consenti à la compétence de la
cour
nous sommes très préoccupés par les
tentatives de la cpi d'exercer sa
juridiction sur le personnalise raéliens
élections la décision de l'ouverture de
l'enquêté de la cpi a aussi été
condamnée par l'état hébreu de ce jeu en
vue la décision de la cour pénale
internationale d'ouvrir aujourd'hui l'
enquête contre israël pour crimes de
guerre est absurde c'est de
l'antisémitisme non diluée sous couvert
d'hypocrisie sans aucune juridiction
elle a décidé que nos braves soldats qui
prennent toutes les précautions pour
éviter les pertes civiles contre les
pires terroristes du monde qui prennent
délibérément pour cible des civils
et ce serait nos soldats les criminels
de guerre l'un des axes de lanquais de
la cpi portera entre autres sur la
guerre de gaza survenu il ya près de
sept ans fatou bensouda estime que des
crimes auraient été commis par les
forces israéliennes
mais l'état hébreu n'est pas le seul
visé par les investigations
le hamas qui contrôle l'enclavé
palestinienne sera aussi dans le viseur
des enquêteurs pour des faits de torture
d'homicides et d'utilisation de
boucliers humains